เฮ
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. É um grande
prazer estar aqui com vocês para mais
uma live.
Me deem, por favor, o feedback se vocês
estão me escutando bem, por gentileza.
Boa noite, Luís Carlos. Boa noite,
Sérgio.
Boa noite, Maria Cláudia,
Maria Helena, Cleidan,
Ana Paula Rodrigues,
Nara Castelo, Ana Silva, Elizabe,
Vera Matos, Eliseu.
Ótimo, todo mundo tá escutando bem?
Vamos continuar aqui então,
pessoal. A gente vai ter que ser bem
objetivo hoje porque nós temos 20 e
tantas perguntas e tem a apresentação
que eu quero mostrar para vocês, que vai
ser a mesma que eu vou estar mostrando
lá em Portugal, tá bom?
Vamos começar a apresentação de slides.
Primeira pergunta.
A taxantina pode ser tomada
constantemente sem precisar parar?
Existe dosagem ideal dependendo da
idade?
Bem, ela pode ser sim tomada
continuamente, sem necessidade de parar,
porque é um suplemento com perfil de
segurança bem importante, bem comprovado
em estudos clínicos.
E a dosagem recomendada para manutenção
é de 4 a 6 mg diários.
pode chegar até 8 mg, não tem nenhum
risco à saúde.
Então, em relação aos benefícios, tem
que tomar em consideração que leva entre
4 a 8 semanas para você realmente sentir
o impacto da taxantina. Então, paciência
é muito importante nesse caso.
Questão de idade, os estudos mostram
segurança para adultos, mas não existem
dados de segurança ainda
muito
fortes para crianças gestantes e
lactantes. Então, é melhor que seja só
adultos. Para idoso não tem
contraindicação.
A melhor absorção ocorre quando você
toma com uma refeição contendo gordura
saudáveis. Tá?
Pode falar um pouco sobre lactoferrina,
benefícios e dosagens. Se eu não me
engano, eu tenho um vídeo sobre isso na
parte aberta, tá? Depois eu vou dar uma
olhada. Bem, a lactoferrina é uma
proteína multifuncional. Ela está
presente no leite materno e também
outras secreções biológicas. Ela tem
propriedades antibacterianas,
antivirais, antifungicas, que são bem
significativas. Então, ela funciona
principalmente sequestrando o ferro,
o que impede a proliferação de patógenos
nocivos, né, de agentes, bactérias
e favorece o crescimento das bactérias
boas. é o caso do lactobacilos e do bife
do bactério. Além disso, ela atua como
potente antiinflamatório imunomodulador,
estimula células de defesa como as
células assassinas naturais natural
killers e protege a integridade da
mucosa intestinal, restaurando a
meostase imunológica. Então a
lactoferrina, ela tem propriedades
antioxidantes, pode proteger o fígado
contra o estresse oxidativo, inclusive
os causados pelo excesso de ferro ou
consumo de álcool. A dosagem, os estudos
falam em torno de 850 mg por dia.
Isso foi utilizado em pesquisas com
crianças e teve 66% de redução de
infecções respiratórias.
Para adultos, a dosagem varia de 250 a
500 mg por dia. Pode chegar a 1 g ou 1,
meio em períodos de maior demanda.
Então, priorize a lactoferrina bovina
isolada, já que quando ela é digerida,
ela se se transforma em lactoferricinas
que são ainda mais potentes que as
lactoferrinas humanas. OK?
Como antioxidante pro sistema
cardiovascular, posso substituir a
comenzima Q10 pela taxantina?
Bem, isso não é um caso de competição,
né? Não é uma substituição direta. Você
pode fazer uma complementação
estratégica. A taxantina é um
antioxidante muito mais potente que a
cozima Q10, né? Os estudos falam até de
800 vezes mais forte. Ela tem um papel
fundamental que alinha perfeitamente com
a teoria do LDL do oxidado, né, que
vocês conhecem, que foi publicado
naquele livro, o mito do colesterol do
Dr. Josef Sinatra.
Então ela previne a oxidação das
partículas de LDL, reduz inflamação,
protege o endotélio
e a coenzima Q10, ela tem uma função
energética mitocondrial bem interessante
em vai ajudar no cérebro, no coração e
vai regenerar outras vitaminas
antioxidantes, como é o caso da vitamina
E da C.
Então eu combinaria e não substituiria
as tachantina entre 4 e 12 mg por dia
com 10 na faixa de 100, 200 a 400 mg por
dia. Bom,
estou pensando em experimentar iudo
tomando lugol 5%.
Duas gotas ao dia. O que que o doutor
acha? Outra dúvida. Estou tomando azul
de metileno PA 1% duas gotas por dia e
peso 58 kg.
Gesta
gestante. É isso? Não entendi. Foi
diagnosticada com osteoporose depois de
quebrar a caneca. A cabeça deve ser, né?
Do fos 57 anos e fazer um exame
deitometria.
Devo tomar o Ivenit.
Ivenity. Não sei qual que é esse remédio
não,
mas vamos lá. Eu não usaria, tá, o iodo
a 5% duas gotas por dia, a não ser que
você tenha certeza que você não tem
que você não tem
e rashimoto, tá? Se você tem certeza que
não tem rashimoto, pode tomar. Agora, se
você tiver, eu não tomaria essa dose. Eu
tomaria a dose que eu já falei em vídeos
anteriores de cerca de 500 microg
combinado iodo com iodeto.
Azul de metileno, você tá na faixa
correta. Tá? A literatura recomenda de
50 a 100 microg dia para uso sublingual
com fins de redução de estresse
oxidativo e cognição.
Eu, na verdade, utilizo na faixa de 20,
30 mg por dia. Eu, particularmente, eu
tomo essa dose, tá?
Considerando seu peso de 58 kg, duas
gotas a 1%, né, do azul de metileno
vai considerar mais ou menos 50 microg.
Tá dose baixa, mas poderia estar
utilizando, tá?
sobre ooporose, o caso é preocupante
pela fratura precoce de coloor.
Então, antes você pensar usar esse
venit, que eu não sei exatamente qual é
a droga, teria que olhar. Eu recomendo
você otimizar agressivamente com
suplementação vitamina D com K2, boro,
silício, cobre, zinco, vitamina A,
magnésio, cálcio, tá? Tudo isso é muito
importante. K2 também, né?
Elimine os alimentos inflamatórios,
glúten leite derivados e com a mais
proteína, faça a musculação e faça nova
densitometria depois de um ano, tá? Se
você não se recuperar nesse período, aí
você pode estar tomando o remédio. Ou se
você preferir tomar o remédio, tome o
mínimo de doses possível e entre com
essa outra parte da medicina funcional.
Doutor, comecei a usar o iodo molecular
adquirido na integrar. Estou sentindo
muitas melhoras, unha, cabelo, bem-estar
geral. Então, gostaria que os familiares
também tomassem. O valor não fica
acessível. A pergunta, se fosse para
tomarlo golpo, ser bem mais barato e
continuar tendo os benefícios de iodo,
quantas gotas não seria prejudicial? De
novo, eu falei isso em vídeo, vou falar
de novo. Tem certeza que não tem
rachimoto? Tu pode tomar duas gotas de
lugol. Você não tem certeza, não tome,
tá
certo?
Por que que eu prefiro molecular
manipulada? Eu explico isso no vídeo por
causa da dose, tá?
Inclusive, o Departamento de Tireoide da
Sociedade Brasileira de Indocrinologia
se posicionou frontalmente e formalmente
contra o uso de Lugol.
Existe um fenômeno chamado efeito wolf
shaikov,
que pode causar hipotiroidismo
transitório quando você toma dose altas
de iodo, tá? Esse é um problema também.
E também existe o risco dos nódulos
tiroidantes captarem o excesso deo e
dispararem uma tirotoxicose, que é um
excesso de hormônio tiroidiano.
Outra alternativa que eu não hoje em dia
não é o meu preferido é o IO do Kelp.
Você pode estar pedindo para eles
adquirirem do Kelp também, tá?
Doutor, pode falar sobre o crominex para
resistência?
É um bom ativo. É, o crominex nada mais
é de uma formulação que tem o cromo
trivalente
associado ao extrato de chilag, né, que
é da medicina iurveda. E o filantos
embl. Esses três potencializam
a biisponibilidade
do cromo, né? e protege contra oxidação.
Então, diferentemente do picolinato
promo, que é o que eu mais prescrevo
pelo custo e facilidade de acesso,
esse caso, picolinato, ele pode ser
convertido em cromoexavalente
e isso pode dar eh proporcionar riscos à
saúde em algumas situações. O Chrominex,
ele evita essa conversão e torna-se sim
uma opção mais segura.
A literatura internacional confirma
então que o cromo melhora os receptores
de insulina e a sensibilidade celular,
especialmente importante para quem tem
resistência insulínica, pré-diabetes ou
sí metabólica. Então é um bom ativo, mas
eu quero deixar claro que funciona de
verdade quando associado a mudança
estilo de vida, tá? Importante não
esquecer das mudanças de estilo de vida,
só ficar confiando no crominex. Então
você pode utilizar 10 mg por dia, uma
cápsula, uma hora antes do almoço e uma
antes da janta.
É normal sentir dor abaixo das costelas,
lado direito, durante o jejum de 22
horas? Eu não recomendo jejum de 22
horas, Cleidan, tá? Eu falei isso em
vídeo recente. Eu recomendo você faça
até 16 horas de jejum.
Quando você faz um jum prolongado assim,
o seu corpo pode passar por adaptações
fisiológicas que podem causar sensações
desconfortáveis na região abdominal, tá?
Inclusive abaixo das costelas. Então
esse incômodo pode estar relacionado ao
espasmo diafragma, pode ser mobilização
biliar da vesícula, que contrai na
quando ele a vesícula contrai, tá, em
resposta à ausência de alimento, OK?
alterações no padrão de gases
intestinais e até mesmo
hipersensibilidade do sistema digestório
durante a transição pro estado de
cetose. Então, se a dor é leve,
transitória, desaparece quando se inicia
a refeição, geralmente faz parte da
adaptação normal do corpo ao jejum
intermitente, tá? Mas tem que ficar
atento. Se a dor for intensa,
persistente, mesmo pode você se
alimentar e tiver acompanhado de outros
sintomas, como é o caso de náusea, né?
vontade de vomitar, febre, criterícia,
né, que é o amarelão na pele, ou se
acontecer, principalmente após refeições
gordurosas, isso pode indicar problemas
de vesícula, fígado ou pâncreas tem que
ser investigado, tá, em consultório.
Beleza?
Pode-se usar o microbiomemex com o
corebiome para potencializar as
bactérias boas do intestino?
Bem, vamos falar dos dois aqui. O
corebiô é um pós biótico, né? E a
tributirina, que é um composto feito com
três moléculas de butirato, ele vai agir
diretamente no intestino grosso no colo.
E o Microbiomex,
ele trabalha modulando a composição do
microbioma para aumentar a produção
interna dos ácidos grásos de cadeia
curta, inclusive o próprio butirato, tá?
Então, teoricamente, eles poderiam ser
utilizados de maneira complementar,
mas na prática pode ser redundante, pode
ser desnecessário, OK? Eu não tenho
muita prática com Microbiomex, eu tenho
mais prática combiome.
A gente não tem uma literatura
clara dizendo essa associação, tá?
Então eu acho que não é uma boa ideia a
princípio
utilizar essa associação.
Você pode fazer é usar um de cada vez,
usar primeiro um, depois o outro e
testar qual dos dois que você se adapta
melhor, tá? Você pode estar fazendo
ciclos de 30 dias a 45 dias de uso de
cada um deles.
Então, para restaurar barreira
intestinal de maneira rápida, o
corebiome pode ser mais direto. Se você
quer reducar o microbioma a longo prazo,
Microbiomex
pode ser interessante.
Boa noite. poderia dizer qual a origem
do problema das pernas inquietas? É
multifatorial, tá? Tem várias causas. É
neurológico, tem tratamento, qual é? Tem
cura?
Bem, a maioria dos casos, ela é
secundária a desequilíbrios que podemos
abordar pela abordagem funcional. Então,
origem pode ser genética em casos
idiopáticos.
Porém, na prática clínica, podemos
encontrar deficiência de ferro como
causa, que é presente em 25% desses
casos aí de pernas inquietas. Pode ser
também desequilíbrio na dopamina
cerebral, pode ser deficiência de ácido
fólico, pode ser problemas renais, pode
ser diabetes compensado, pode ser uso
excessivo de cafeína ou álcool, pode ser
o hábito de fumar, pode ser medicamentos
como antidepressivos e antihistamínicos.
que é o antialérgico, né? Então a gente
tem que tentar afastar todas essas
causas inflamatórias aí e repor o que
tem que ser reposto
e não tem uma cura definitiva, tá? Não
tem uma cura definitiva no sentido
convencional, mas podemos corrigir todas
as deficiências que nós encontrarmos.
Pensamento de ferro B12, ácido fórico,
vitamina D, eliminar os alimentos
inflamatórios, os irritantes
da dieta, né? Os alimentos processados,
melhorar a qualidade do sono, reduzir
estresse, ansiedade, fazer exercício
físico regular, avaliar medicamentos que
possam estar piorando o quadro, tá?
Então, com essa abordagem de medicina
funcional, a maioria dos pacientes têm
uma boa melhora disso daí.
Existe alguma maneira de reverter a
catarata ou a cirurgia seria a única
opção. Existe, tá, colírios à base de
carnosina que podem ajudar em casos
iniciais, tá, da catarata.
Mas se a catarata já tiver bem
desenvolvida,
aí vai ter que realmente fazer a troca
do cristalino,
tá? Então você pode procurar o o coleiro
de N carnosina, tá?
O acetilcosina também pode ser que eh
hoje em dia tá mais difícil de
encontrar, mas a Life extension tem esse
colírio e algumas manipulações
oftalmológicas podem ter.
Se eu não me engano é carnosina 1% esse
colírio aí,
mas tiver que fazer a cirurgia, faz
porque é uma cirurgia geralmente bem
segura, tá?
Como é que você previne com uma
alimentação baixa em carboidrato, baixa
em açúcar, processado industrializado,
evitar contato dos olhos com raios
ultravioleta, então usar óculos escuro
quando tiver exposto ao sol, manter uma
alimentação rica em antioxidantes com
luteínas e a chantina, vitamina C,
vitamina E, tá? Não fumar, evitar o uso
de corticovide, que é uma causa também
de catarata.
Beleza?
Ataingestão de proteínas provoca a
ativação do receptor do hormônio do
crescimento, que por sua vez aumenta os
níveis de insulina de IGF1, cuja maior
concentração está associada
respectivamente ao diabetes e ao câncer.
O Dr. Alan Carita nisso. São palavras
Dr. Walter Longo.
Hum. Parcialmente eu acredito nisso, tá?
Então, existe sim esse mecanismo de
ativação do GF1 pela proteína animal,
OK? Isso pode, em alguns casos, aumentar
a sustentabilidade ao câncer, pode
alguns casos acelerar o envelhecimento,
mas o que eu vejo na prática, a maioria
das pessoas vai comer pouca proteína e
muito carboidrato, não é? A não ser
homem, né? Homem que gosta de comer
muita carne, churrasco, pode ter esse
problema aí. Agora, as mulheres em geral
elas não comem tanta proteína e comem
muito carboidrato, tá?
Então não podemos demonizar toda e
qualquer proteína porque supostamente
toda proteína vai aumentar o GF1. Vamos
ser inteligente na estratégia, né? Então
vamos evitar sobrecarga de proteína
animal,
né? Vamos privilegiar fontes e peixe
rico e ômega-3, ovos caipiras, né?
Vamos utilizar as proteínas de origem
vegetal, mas vamos reduzir um pouquinho
a carne vermelha, mas não tem nessa
necessidade de ficar obsecado com
redução de proteína, tá? Como eu tô
dizendo,
é importante a qualidade da proteína, o
tipo de fonte, o contexto nutricional
geral. Como eu falei, é muito mais comum
as pessoas errarem no carboidrato que na
proteína, especialmente as mulheres.
Homens que são excessivamente tarado em
carne vermelha, pode ser um problema
isso aqui que você tá falando, tá?
E a atividade física protege bastante
contra esses problemas também, porque
essa proteína vai virar aminoácido que
vai pro músculo, né? Então, a atividade
física é bem protetora nesse ponto.
Então, alguém que treina a força de
maneira adequada,
né, vai ter muito menos chance de
acontecer esse problema aí, tá bom?
É porque o longo ele vende lá aquela
dieta que imita o jejum intermitente,
tá? Então ele tem um pouquinho de
conflito de interesse nessas alegações
que ele faz aí, que ele precisa vender o
produto dele, OK?
Na live retrasada, perguntei a você
sobre tomar o suplemento relora. Até
quanto tempo
antes da musculação e a partir de quanto
tempo antes da musculação? E percebi que
você estranhou a pergunta e disse que
não tem uma recomendação do reló para
musculação. É um suplemento tomado à
noite para ajudar no sono. E eu vi
perguntado isso porque na live que você
fez com Gil, ele recomendou
o suplemento relora.
antes da musculação para impedir ou
diminuir o aumento do cortisol, tá? Eu
não lembro disso, tá? Eh,
ele deve ter falado isso, mas eu não
tenho essa experiência com reló para
isso. Se você souber de alguma
recomendação do suplemento reló antes da
musculação, então você conversa com o
Gil lá, ele tem as redes sociais dele,
ele tem o Instagram dele, você pode
perguntar para ele, tá? E esse tempo aí
que você tá tão preocupado, isso não é
relevante não, ô Eliseu, você fica se
prendendo umas coisas que não tem
porquê.
Toma meia hora antes e pronto. Não fica
pensando tanto assim nesse nesse nesse
intervalo de tempo, tá? Tá complicando
uma coisa que não precisa ser
complicada, não. Tá,
tá? A ideia do do Gil quando ele falou
isso é que realmente o Relora poderia
baixar o cortisol em quem tem pico de
cortisol, tá? Antes do treino. Se a
pessoa tá estressada com pico de
cortisol, ela tomaria o relora. para
poder ficar mais calma na musculação e
ter mais rendimento, porque o cortisol
atrapalha, né, a parte anabólica,
entendeu?
Você criaria um ambiente hormonal mais
favorável para anabolismo e menos
catabólico quando você toma o relora.
Mas não fica assim, ah, tem que ser 30,
45 ou 55 minutos antes do trem. Toma um
negócio e pronto. Não fica fosforilando,
Eliseu, entendeu? Escolhe um período aí
meia hora antes.
Não tem essa padronização na literatura
internacional, você entende? Tá? Escolhe
um horário entre 60 e 30 minutos antes
da da atividade, tá?
E pergunta pro Gil lá na no Instagram
dele sobre isso, tá? De repente ele tem
uma experiência prática com isso, porque
ele é médico esportivo, tá?
Dr. Alan, o meu irmão é meu vizinho e
ele criou um galinheiro no meu quintal,
sendo que esse galinheiro fica
localizado exatamente a 10 m do meu
quarto. Supondo que esse galinheiro
possa transmitir vírus e ou doenças para
humanos. Como faço para me prevenir?
Nossa senhora, 10 m do seu quarto
galinheiro.
Bem, eu andei vendo um pouco sobre isso,
tá? Os resultados de busca mostram que
galinheiros em área urbana pode
representar risco real de transmissão de
salmonela e pode ser vetores para o
mosquito palha que transmite a
leximaniose.
Então, seria melhor você sair desse
quarto e ficar no outro quarto mais
longe ou você transferir esse galinheiro
para outro lugar. Tá bom? E tem uma
legislação que eu não sabia, eu fui
atrás por causa da sua pergunta, tá? tem
uma jurisprudência brasileira que os
galinheiros precisam ficar no mínimo 50
m de distância, tá? Então você tem
respaldo legal para exigir a remoção do
galinheiro, OK?
Não sei como é que é seu relacionamento
com esse irmão, conversa de boas com
ele, mas se ele ele recusar, você pode
notificar ele pela justiça, tá?
Enquanto isso, tenta fortalecer sua
defesa imunológica com vitamina D, com
zinc, vitamina C, ômega3, tá bom?
Ah, naquela live o eu vou ter que rever
essa live aí porque o Eliseu cismou com
a live. Vamos lá. Naquela live você fez
com o Dr. Gil Kerginski, ele disse que o
melhor suplemento que existe para fazer
o corpo descansar da musculação é o CBD.
Você sabe dizer se o CBD faz o corpo
descansar completamente 24 horas? Caso a
resposta seja afirmativa, então eu posso
tomar o CBD para treinar o mesmo músculo
por dois dias seguidos.
O CBD tem ação defamatória,
analgésica, ajuda a modular o cortisol.
A literatura mais recente que eu
consultei não permite afirmar que ele
promove recuperação muscular completa em
24 horas. Não tem literatura falando
isso, tá? Tem uma revisão da UNIFESP de
2023 que conclui que o nível de
evidência dos efeitos CBD na recuperação
muscular ainda é baixo porque tem pouco
estudo, OK?
Em poucos ensaios clínicos.
O que nós temos em relação aos estudos é
que 93% dos usuários relatam benefício
subjetivo, mas isso não significa
recuperação fisiológica completa em 24
horas, tá? Então não tenho como te
passar essa informação, não tem esses
dados disponíveis, tá?
O melhor é você treinar um grupo
muscular, no dia seguinte você treinar
outro grupo muscular, no terceiro dia
outra sequência. Então, fazer essa
alternância de pelo menos três tipos de
treinos, tá? É melhor você fazer assim.
Então, por exemplo, um dia você treina
bíceps e costa, outro dia você treina
tríceps e peito, no outro dia treina
perna, tá? Vai, faz um, um para três
assim, OK?
Porque a recuperação muscular é muito
importante pós treinar.
Não tem porque você ficar estimulando
demais o músculo com com
excessivamente, entendeu?
Ã, pode tomar na 600 mg diariamente e de
forma ininterrupta ou é preferível tomar
por uns 90 dias e suspender por 30 dias?
Na gente, é aminoácido, tá? Não tem
necessidade de interromper, tá?
Ele é muito seguro para uso contínuo.
Ele tá no mercado há mais de 60 anos e
estudos demonstram que indivíduos
saudáveis toleram bem dose de área de
600 a 1200 mg de forma indefinida.
Portanto, não tem necessidade de fazer
ciclos de pausa, OK?
Lembrando que o NAC ele é o precursor da
gluta junto com a glicina e a e o ácido
glutâmico, só que ele é aminoácido mais
difícil dos três.
Então vale a pena tomar contínuo, sim,
se você puder. E se não puder, não tem
problema nenhum. Você tomar 90 dias para
um mês ou para dois e volta tomar 90,
não tem problema nenhum, tá bom? O
horário é tomar com alimentos. Então
você pode tomar depois do almoço, depois
do jantar, pode dividir também depois do
café da manhã ou do jantar, ok?
Vale a pena tomar contínuo se você
puder.
Doutor, uma criança que quando era bebê
sorria normal. Mas de novo essa
história, gente. Essa pergunta se repete
toda hora.
Gente, eu respondi essa pergunta já tem
uns quatro vezes já. Essa pergunta,
vamos lá. Eu acho que é a mesma
pergunta.
Uma criança que quando era bebê sorria
normal, era ativa, brincava com outros
bebês, brincava com amigos na rua, mas
não era extremamente extrovertida, era
elogiado pelos adultos como criança
comunicativa. Gente, escreve um livro
não, gente, faz isso não. Entendeu?
Quando fez 8 anos, foi pro interior do
Ceará e ficou até mais ou menos uns 10
anos. Quando tinha nove, ele lembra que
gostava muito de ir paraa escola pelo
recreio, depois voltou pro Rio de
Janeiro e lá ficava mais de em casa não
tinha irmãos e os pais tinham medo da
violência.
Não teve interesse de estudar, repetiu
de ano, ficou envergonhado. Caramba,
gente, não acaba esse negócio.
Ficou envergonhado por ter sido
reprovado, garantiu para si mesmo querer
estudar, né? Tá, eu vou ler, eu vou
parar de ler aqui eh em voz alta, eu vou
ler, sabe, em silêncio, tá?
Ah.
Bem, o que você descreve, se eu
conseguir entender tudo, porque é
difícil ler um texto tão longo assim,
sem ter divisão por parágrafos, tá? Isso
seria mais compatível com o
desenvolvimento secundário de sintomas
obsessivos compulsivos
induzidos pelo ambiente do que o autismo
clássico. OK? Essa pergunta parecia
muito com as perguntas de lives
anteriores, mas não acho que não. Eh,
na verdade eu acho que é a mesma
pergunta reformulada.
Mas gente, o objetivo das lives não é
fazer diagnóstico, não. É simplesmente
orientar vocês, tá?
Mas assim, voltando, parece mais um
sintoma obsessivo compusível,
porque houve essa mudança abrupta de
padrão comportamental após introdução de
telas massiva.
Então, a literatura recente mostra que
obsessões e compulsões podem se
desenvolver a partir dos ou 4 anos de
idade em crianças predispostas.
Os fatores ambientais são tão
importantes quanto a genética, OK?
Isso de acordo com os estudos sobre
toque infantil. Então, nesse caso
específico, você tem todos os gatilhos,
exposição excessiva à tela, né? privação
de luz solar e dopamento desregulada.
Tem privação de sono crônica.
Isso destrói a cognição, aumenta
ansiedade. Tem comportamentos
compulsíveis em cascata, né, que é jogo,
rede social, masturbação.
Isso retroalimentar a disfunção
dopaminégica e também os comportamentos
repetitivos.
Então, se fosse autismo, o psiquiatra
teria observado sinais precoces, mais
óbvios nas primeiras avaliações,
e o padrão não seria tão claramente
desencadeado pela tecnologia. Então,
parece que é uma combinação de
predisposição genética para ansiedade
associada ao dano ambiental severo pela
tecnologia, excesso de telas, tá? Então,
essa masturbação compulsível pornografia
agravam a desegulação dopaminérgica.
cria circuitos neurais de recompensa que
são patológicos
e isso pode imitar um espectro autista,
dando dificuldade social, contato visual
reduzido, movimentos repetitivos,
foco hiperconcentrado.
O isolamento social pode ter atrapalhado
e pode ter contribuído aí para pra
doença. Afinal de contas, as crianças
precisam de luz solar, precisa de
estímulo, precisa de contato com outras
crianças, interação, tá?
Então, minha recomendação seria
investigar radicalmente a retirada de
estímulos digitais,
restar ciclo sono vigília, né, com
terapia de luz, alterar, aumentar
a atividade física ao ar livre e fazer
uma orientação aí com o nutricionista e
com o médico da
da minha linha aí da medicina funcional.
Pessoal, eu vou criar um um limite de
texto, tá, para as perguntas, porque tá
difícil,
tá? Eu vou criar um limite de texto. Se
passar do limite, eu a pergunta vai ser
excluída do documento, tá?
Pessoas que têm depressão, ansiedade ou
esquizofrenia, você recomenda quantas
cápsulas 3, mega DH Vitafor? Isso é
suficiente ou recomenda três?
Bem, cada cápsula tem apenas 300 mg de
EPA e tem 1500 mg de DHA. Então ele é um
dos produtos mais concentrados em DH no
mercado.
Então para depressão, esquizofrenia,
ansiedade, a evidência aponta que você
precisa de EPA entre 1000 a 2000 por
dia.
Então seria bom você associar esse
Megadh
Vitafor, uma cápsula por dia, com um
outro produto mais rico em EPA, tá?
Então seria bom você usar dois tipos de
ômega-3 aí, uma cápsula desse da
fora aí.
Aliás, Mega DHA da Vitaf
com outro produto mais em EPA, tá?
Seria isso aí.
Ah, sobre telas e pornografia, o
trabalho do Dr. Gary Wilson, sintomas de
autismo induzido por tela e pornografia.
Se durante 90 dias o indivíduo ficar sem
estímulos, pode voltar ao normal.
Bem, esse Dr. Gary Wilson,
ele foi um pesquisador importante que
documentou como um consumo compulsível
de pornografia afeta a neuroplasticidade
cerebral, particularmente através do
circuito de recompensa dopaminésico, tá?
Então ele não especificamente descreveu
autismo induzido, mas sim disfunções
cerebrais com défic de atenção, falta de
motivação, anedonia, né, que seria falta
de interesse nas coisas e problemas de
desempenho sexual. Então isso pode
coexistir com características autistas
préexistentes ou que parecem autistas,
tá? O período de 90 dias é uma
referência prática para fazer o detox
desse padrão de hipercitação neurológica
durante o qual o cérebro pode começar a
restaurar a sensibilidade dopaminégica.
Então, a recuperação completa depende de
vários fatores, a duração da exposição,
a intensidade do vício, a idade da
pessoa ou se existem outras disfunções
metabólicas ou inflamação cerebral
envolvido. Então, 3 meses geralmente é
suficiente para notar melhoras
significativas em energia, concentração
e função sexual, mas a recalibração
neural completa pode levar mais tempo,
geralmente entre 6 e 12 meses. Também
muito importante tratar inflamação
sistêmica através da retirada de
alimentos inflamatórios, tá?
Então, comece com a eliminação completa
das telas estimulantes,
mas tem que fazer uma abordagem
holística, né, com nutrientes, com
acompanhamento nutricional,
médico, etc., tá? e ver os exames. Então
tem que se passar em médico.
Doutor, em seu vídeo recente sobre
berberina, o ideal seria encontrar o
cloro hidrato berberina ou as doses
citadas são referentes à beberina
extrato seco.
Então, eu tava me referindo à beberina
cloridrato, tá? HCl.
O extrato seco é um extrato padronizado
que tem um percentual de coridrate e
beberina em torno de 97%, alguns casos
90%.
Então quando você vê um produto de 500
mg de beberina HCL, são realmente 500 mg
na molécula ativa, mas quando é extrato
seco pode ter entre 90 e 97% do
cloridrato de berina.
Então eu tava recomendando cloridade
bermelina mesmo, tá? Entre 500 mg por
dia ou duas a três vezes ao dia, tá?
Essa é a forma mais pesquisada e com
biodisponibilidade estabelecida.
Então vá direto na beberina HCL de fonte
confiável. E se você conseguir o
fitossoma de beberina que combina com
fosfolipídeos,
é melhor ainda, tá? que aumenta
significativamente a absorção.
Então tem que olhar no rótulo se tá
escrito beberin HCL500 ou se é extrato
padronizado. Então prefira o HCL. Mas se
você comprar o extrato, você tem que
calcular quantos miligram reais de
beberina tá recebendo
e tome 30 minutos antes das efeições
principais.
Boa noite, Dr. Alan. Boa noite. Qual o
melhor procedimento para neuropatia nas
pernas e pés? Membros inferiores
extremamente inchados, panturrilha,
tonozelo, pé. Paciente idosa, sobrepeso
histórico de trombose bilateral. Sente
dor até mesmo com contato leve do lençol
e refere não sentir os dedos dos pés.
Aí tem um monte de problema junto, né?
uma convergência, inflamação sistêmica
elevada, disfunção vascular, né, por
causa da história de trombose, edema
significativo e neuropatia com
componente ágico, né, com dor
importante. Então, minha primeira
preocupação é investigar profundamente
as causas, né, não só tratar os
sintomas. Então tem que ver todos os
exames, passar em consulta, né? Faça uma
avaliação com um bom angiologista, uma
boa flebologista, uma boa cirurgia
vascular
para descartar comprometimento venoso e
linfático,
fazer análise completa de deficiências
nutricionais do complexo B, vitamina D,
ácido fólico
e ferro também, né? Vê se não tem
problema de ferro, ver como é que tá o
grau de de diabetes, né? Se a pessoa for
diabética, que é a causa mais comum de
neuropatia,
vê como é que tá a homocisteína, tudo
isso tá aí, entendeu?
Então a gente tem que ver as causas
dessa neuropatia que mais comum é o
diabetes.
pode estar fazendo também drenagem
linfática, ajuda
eliminar os alimentos inflamatórios,
suplementar com alfalipoico, que é o
principal suplemento aí pra neuropatia,
elcarnitina, pode usar também berberina,
bioreron, se tiver um anímia importante,
anemia não, desculpa, um diabetes
importante ou pré-diabetes,
tem que ver se não tem metais pesados
que estão causando neuropatia,
pode usar um creme de capsaicina atópica
que é muito bom para as neuropatias
assim.
H,
tá? Então, tem que fazer uma avaliação
completa desse caso. Aí
no seu vídeo recente você disse usar 600
mg magnésio elementar 8 a 12 semanas.
Juntamente com isso, tem uma fórmula
especial para quem é muito sensível ao
magnésio, está precisando repor rápido.
Tem o magnésio lactato, mas tá com muita
dificuldade de achar isso aí. Eu tentei
colocar
uma prescrição de um paciente, mas a
farmacêutica não conseguiu achar.
Na falta do lactato, você pode usar o
glicina, o glicinato, né, em doses
menores e subindo aos poucos,
porque a forma da magnésioglicina tem
menor efeito laxante, tá? Você pode usar
também o magnésio taurato,
certo? Que a taurina também é uma boa.
Pode também, por um tempo usar magnésio
pela pele transdérmico, né, para evitar
problemas intestinais.
Beleza?
Cháve bem forte de sucupida miúda.
Tendinite, bustite, quanto tempo posso
usar?
Sucupira tem excelente ação
antiinflamatória, mas tem que tomar um
certo cuidado. Não recomendo o uso
contínuo indefinido.
O protocolo mais seguro
é utilizar 15 dias tomando o chá bem
forte de 1 L a 2 por dia, depois 7 dias
de pausa e assim sucessivamente conforme
necessário. Então isso evita que o
organismo se acostume e perca eficácia,
além de minimizar com aquele efeito
colateral por uso prolongado. Então
durante esses 15 dias você pode
intensificar o uso sem problema. E
depois de dois a três ciclos completos,
você pode
avaliar a resposta com o médico, tá? Se
a dor melhorou significativamente, você
pode fazer pausas maiores ou usar de
forma mais esporádica.
Mas se ainda estiver inflamado, continua
o protocolo cíclico,
tá? Então tem que ficar fazendo essa
alternância, tá? 15 dias sim, 7 dias
não.
Dr. Alão, DMSO é melhor que o iodo para
o tratamento de miomas? É possível curar
os miomas ainda pequenos com essas
alternativas?
45 anos menstruando e ainda quase
chegando na menopausa.
Os dois tem ação, tá?
Tem ação,
probabilidades antiinflamatórias.
O iodo tem maior potencial aí de ao
longo prazo coral mioma.
Mas o a questão do mioma vai mais
embaixo, né? Tem muito a ver com o
desequilíbrio hormonal, deficiência de
vitamina D, inflamação sistêmica. Então
tem que combater essas causas aí,
inflamação e desequilíbrio hormonal.
Então, tem que tirar os alimentos
inflamatórios, tem que reequilibrar os
hormônios,
usar o magnésio, ômeega-3,
mas você pode usar o DMSO junto com o
iodo, não tem por escolher um ou outro,
pode usar os dois, né?
DMSO dissolve pedra na vesícula? Não,
desinflama hérneia de disco. Sim. E
paraa nevralgia do trigo pode ser usado?
Sim. Tá.
Então pra inflamação edema em herne de
disco cervical tem relatos promissores
de melhora, especialmente quando a gente
combina com outras estratégias como
redução de alimentos inflamatórios
e suporte com magnésio, vitamina
complexo B.
Primeiro tem que investigar
profundamente as causas
ligados à informação sistêmica,
sensibilidades alimentares.
Aí você pode utilizar o DMSO tópico 70%
aplicado na região cervical, duas a três
vezes ao dia, associado com o
antiinflamatório oral, curcumina de alta
absorção e bosuéia serrata. Pode usar
também o pea, né, o palmito etanolamina.
faz um repouso adequado. Tá bom?
Então você esse seria o protocolo. Deixa
eu ver se tem mais alguns. Tem. Dr.
Alan, curvatura congênita piniana tem
que ser obrigatoriamente cirurgia? Não,
eu respondi semana passada.
Eu acho que a pessoa não viu a live da
semana passada e tá repetindo a
pergunta, tá?
Então, eu já respondi isso na semana
passada. Eh, na verdade, se o grau de
curvatura
for pequeno, não precisa fazer cirurgia,
tá? E esse Dr. Egídio aí é no Brasil
supostamente o melhor cirurgião de pênis
curto congênito do do Brasil, tá? Então
ele é um cara que tem muita reputação.
Se ele tá alegando que ao invés de fazer
a cirurgia do lado normal, ele faz do
lado torto.
Ã, é o seguinte, você tá curvado assim,
ó, tá? Eh, qual que seria o lado torto
que você tá falando? Porque geralmente a
cirurgia é feita aqui, ó, tá? É feito um
ponto aqui para retificar o pênis. O
problema é que ao você fazer esse ponto,
você encurta o pênis, tá? Então eu não
sei se tá querendo dizer qual que é o
lado torto, porque a a tortuosidade tem
a convexidade
e tem a concavidade, né? Convexidade e
concavidade. Você tá falando de fazer do
lado da convexidade ou da concavidade,
entendeu? Mas o se ele falou, ele sabe o
que tá falando, porque ele é o maior
especialista de de cirurgia piniana no
Brasil. Até onde eu sei,
obrigatoriamente tem que fazer teste de
glicose de cetose para saber se está
mesmo na cetose da dieta cetogênica.
Tem. Primeiro faz o teste de glicose,
depois de um mês testando a glicose com
aquele monitor contínuo. Aí você pode
começar a medir a cetose, tá? É
importante porque no começo geralmente
você tem que ver se você não tá comendo
carboidrato demais, então tem que
controlar o glicose. Depois de um mês
você acertando isso aí você vai pra
segunda etapa que é para ver como é que
estão os níveis de copos cetônicos, tá?
Essa que é a sequência.
Como evitar esse mosquito? Eu tenho um
galinheiro com 12 aves, fica chão de
terra próximo outras casas. É tirar o
galinheiro de lá, meu. É o que eu
expliquei para você. Não pode ficar 10 m
distância, tem que ficar pelo menos 50,
tá? Ã, tem muro de 2 m, minha casa não
tem janela virada para esse garinheiro.
Então melhor para você, você tem um muro
alto e não tem janela,
né? Então você tá menos exposto, tá?
Como evitar esse mosquito? Coloca a tela
na janela de mosquito, né? e usa na
época que tiver mais mosquito de chuva,
você usa um uns repelentes e aqueles
aparelhos elétricos que põe na tomada.
Cara, eu preferia não fazer essa super
live, não.
Falar de masturbação é um assunto muito
delicado, né?
Ah, você tá falando da live da
comunidade fechada, né?
Ah, tá, podemos fazer, mas aí seria bom.
Deixa eu fazer então a uma enquete aqui
no canal. Canal não, né? No grupo para
saber quantas pessoas estariam
interessadas. Esse assunto muito
nichado, né?
Eu quero saber quantas pessoas estariam
interessadas
eh
nesse assunto, né?
Deixa eu falar aqui. Perigo sobre telas
e pornografias para a saúde. Vocês
querem esse assunto paraa live da
comunidade de estudos avançados?
Colocar aqui sim.
Não, vamos ver que que o pessoal fala.
Tá?
Então, se a maioria disser, eu coloco
esse assunto na live do dos estudos
avançados, tá?
Pronto, terminamos aqui.
Ã,
ele fez essa live com o filho do Lai
Ribeiro.
Gente, eu não vou, eu vou ver, dar uma
olhada aqui rapidinho nas
perguntas aqui
vocês colocaram ao vivo, tá? Elise, eu
não vou responder as dúvidas ao vivo,
tá?
Boa noite. Boa noite.
Pessoal, vocês querem que eu apresente a
a minha aula que eu vou dar lá em
Portugal, que é de 20 minutos de
duração, mais ou menos? Que que vocês
querem que eu faça?
Dr. Otávio de Melo diz que o azul de
metileno líquido não funciona. Eu tomo
em cápsula e manda tomar cistex que tem
o azul. Não sei de onde que tirou isso,
tá? Ô Maria Helena, não sei de onde
tirou isso.
Pessoal, vocês que não estão
acompanhando ao vivo, assiste as lives
depois, porque senão fica repetindo as
perguntas, tá?
O pessoal não assiste a live, aí repete
a pergunta no na outra semana. Tá
acontecendo isso com uma certa
frequência.
Tô olhando aqui a os comentários de
vocês, tá?
Onde está a enquete? Eu coloquei lá no
Ó, já tem três pessoas responderam já a
enquete desse assunto aí.
OK. Ana Lúcia tá falando que gostaria de
ouvir a apresentação de Portugal. Tá, eu
vou fazer a apresentação aqui. Ah,
Elizabeth escreveu sim. A Vilma, sim,
Cleedivan, sim, Veramatos, sim. Então,
deve ser tudo relativo à apresentação,
né?
Vamos colocar ela aqui no ar, então. Só
um minuto.
Ah, acho melhor importar o PDF. Vamos
lá.
Vamos lá.
Ué, por que que eu não tô achando aqui?
Que coisa. Pera aí, acho que eu vou ter
que apresentar a tela mesmo. Pera aí.
Vou fazer isso que é melhor, porque tá
dando um problema aqui.
Ah, stop screen,
share screen.
Pronto.
Vamos lá então, pessoal.
Bem, a doença de Alzheimer atingiu
proporções epidêmicas e representa um
desafio muito grande, profundo e
crescente para todo o sistema de saúde
do mundo inteiro.
A escala absoluta da crise, que foi
somada a décadas de sucesso terapêutico
limitado, criou um imperativo
estratégico para explorar e validar
novos paradigmas. Então, por um tempo
muito longo, a nossa abordagem foi
restringida por um foco estreito em
monoterapias. Isso gerou resultados
decepcionantes e deixou milhões de
famílias sem opções e desamparadas.
Então, aconteceu o momento de reavaliar
fundamentalmente a compreensão dessa
doença devastadora. Temos projeções aí
para que 2050 nós vamos ter 152 milhões
de casos de Alzheimer no mundo inteiro.
Então vai ser um dos problemas mais
graves que nós vamos ter como sociedade.
Então Alzheimer é a principal causa de
declínio incognitivo associado à idade.
É considerada a terceira principal causa
de morte nos Estados Unidos, ficando
atrás apenas de doenças cardiovasculares
e câncer. A doença afeta
desproporcionalmente as mulheres que são
aí a rimo de família, representam
aproximadamente 65% dos casos das
mulheres, constitui também a grande
maioria dos cuidadores. Então, além do
imenso curso social indireto dessa
doença, direto e indireto, temos que
levar em consideração a enorme carga
financeira, emocional que se coloca em
cima dos cuidadores, especialmente das
nossas queridas mulheres.
Então, temos que entender que a
Alzheimer não é um sinal normal de
envelhecimento, é um processo patológico
progressivo que demanda uma estratégia
terapêutica sofiscada.
Então, a história do desenvolvimento de
medicamentos para Alzheimer é uma lição
muito marcante sobre as limitações de
uma abordagem de alvo único. Nós temos
que fazer uma transição mais rápido
possível da visão de monoterapia ou
biterapia paraa abordagem multifatorial.
Durante as últimas décadas, centenas de
ensaios clínicos, custando bilhões de
dólares, foram conduzidos sem produzir
qualquer sucesso significativo na
melhora cognitiva. Isso em oposição a
meramente uma desaceleração do declínio.
Então isso contrasta de maneira muito
nítida com os grandes avanços observados
em outras doenças crônicas complexas. é
o caso da doença cardiovascular, do HIV,
onde terapias combinadas transformaram
os desfechos dos pacientes. Então, o
foco estreito do campo tem sido um
impedimento muito grande, essa mania,
essa obsessão com o Betam Miloide. Isso
foi o que disse o Dr. Long Schneider,
que é um pesquisador líder em Alzheimer,
ele observou de maneira muito apropriada
os amiloides, né, que aquelas proteínas
alteradas, né, que tem no Alzheimer,
sugaram todo o ar da sala, né, impediram
uma exploração mais abrangente da
natureza multifacetada dessa doença.
Então, essa história de fracasso, ele
sublinha a necessidade urgente de uma
mudança fundamental de paradigma em como
nós conceitualizamos, diagnosticamos e
tratamos o declínio cognitivo.
Então, é muito importante termos um novo
paradigma e entender a doença como uma
rede multifatorial. Então, a mudança de
paradigma necessária envolve a transição
de modelo de alvo único para uma
perspectiva de biologia de sistemas.
Então, esse novo arcabolso,
ele reformula o declínio cognitivo não
como uma doença única, com uma causa
única, mas como um resultado fisiológico
protetor da resposta do cérebro a
múltiplos insultos sistêmicos
simultâneos. Então, é o entendimento que
a doença é multifatorial.
A importância estratégica desse modelo,
ele alinha a abordagem terapêutica com a
natureza complexa de rede da doença.
O princípio científico central do Ricode
é que o Alzheimer é uma doença crônica
resultante do desequilíbrio associado à
idade entre processos que formam
sinapse, conexão tres neurônios, ou
seja, sinaptoblástico e os sinais
sinaptoclásticos, que é destruição de
sinapses. Então, à medida que nós
envelhecemos, o lado instrutivo da
equação frequentemente domina e elevando
a perda líquida de sinapses, que
caracteriza o declínio cognitivo.
Então, no centro dessa dinâmica, tá?
Proteína precursora de amiloide, a
appunia
esse equilíbrio. Então, quando o cérebro
tá saudável,
então a app ela é civada em um único
sítio, em um único ponto por uma enzima.
e produz dois peptídeos protetores que
nutrem o crescimento neuronal e mantém
as conexões sinápticas. São os peptídeos
antes aos aqui do canto esquerdo da
tela.
Quando o cérebro tá sob ameaça de
inflamação, excesso de glicose, toxina,
falta de vitaminas ou falta de
hormônios, a app ela é quebrada em três
sítios diferentes. Então essa ação
produz quatro peptídeos, quatro
fragmentos que ativamente vão dirigir a
perda sináptica e a morte neuronal,
incluindo o peptídeo betamilóide tão
famoso que forma as placas
características. Então, o objetivo
primário do protocolo recode é
identificar e abordar as ameaças
específicas que causam essa mudança.
Então, promovendo o equilíbrio da
sinalização de volta para o estado
protetor, né, a quebra do app em somente
dois fragmentos que vai aumentar a
sinapses.
Então, para ilustrar porque essa
abordagem multifacetada é tão
importante, o Dr. De Bradson criou essa
analogia do teto com 36 buracos. Se o
seu teto tem dezenas de vazamentos,
remendar só um buraco com uma droga só
não vai resolver. Não adianta você
tampar muito bem só um buraco, isso não
vai impedir a inundação. Então os
buracos não são aleatórios. Eles
representam dezenas de mecanismos
moleculares específicos. que o Tubrez
identificou, incluindo aqueles que
governam a função mitocondrial,
sinalização de fatores neurotróficos,
inflamação, vias de detox e a própria
degradação do betamiloide. Então essa
metáfora explica poderosamente o
fracasso consistente do modelo de
medicamento único, né? um buraco só e um
remendo só, que seria o remédio único.
Então esse acaboço teórico leva
diretamente a necessidade prática de
diagnósticos abrangentes para
identificar cada potencial buraco para
cada paciente individual.
Então, é muito importante nós
implementarmos um sistema bem
estruturado de avaliação.
Isso significa uma cognoscopia e
subtipagem de pacientes. Então, para
você ter uma terapia multifatorial
eficaz e personalizada, tem que fazer
essa avaliação diagnóstica abrangente
para identificar os impulsionadores
específicos do declínio cognitivo único
para cada indivíduo. essa avaliação
profunda e personalizada que vai
permitir a criação de um plano de
tratamento direcionado e efetivo.
Então nós temos aí na tela que eu vou
falar um pouco melhor adiante os tipos,
os seis tipos do Alzheimer, tipo um
inflamatório, que é causado por agentes
inflamatórios como intestino
hiperpermeável, dieta ruim, infecções, o
tipo 1.5 C, que é a resistência
insulínica, o diabetes tipo 3 cerebral,
que é causado por uma dieta ruim e
também uma genética favorável diabetes.
E é tratado com a dieta baixa em
carboidratos, jejum e uso de
medicamentos hipoglicemiantes, o tipo
dois atrófico, que é a falta de
substâncias que vão melhorar as conexões
entre os neurônios, né, como se fosse os
adubos cerebrais, que são os hormônios,
os nutrientes e o exercício.
O tipo três, que é o tipo tóxico, que é
exposição a substâncias no meio ambiente
que vão intoxicar e causar dano
neurológico. E o tratamento é com
protocolos de detox e osquelantes. O
tipo quatro vascular, que é a falta de
irrigação cerebral no cérebro.
Isso vai ser tratado aí com substâncias
que melhor a circulação, terapias oxig
com oxigênio, né, terapias oxidativas e
também com a os exercícios de
cardiorespiratórios.
O tipo cinco traumático, que é causado
por traumas repetidos na cabeça e é
tratado com reabilitação direcionada e
descanso cerebral.
Então é muito importante na avaliação
diagnóstica do Recode, que é bem
extensa, fornecer os principais inputs
pro algoritmo, que é uma o software que
eles desenvolveram para ajudar a
determinar eh qual é o papel de cada
tipo desses seis tipos que eu acabei de
falar. Então, esse software identifica
os potenciais contribuidores para o
declínio cognitivo de indivíduo, tá?
Então é análise de numerosos
biomarcadores. Aí eu não vou entrar em
detalhes aqui pelo tempo da palestra,
mas você tem que verificar marcadores
inflamatórios, hormonais, de nutrientes,
de metais pesados e toxinas. Quando
possível fazer avaliação genética
também. Eh, também tem ferramentas aí de
avaliação eh que são padronizadas, como
é o caso dos testes moca, do slams, eh,
testes computadorizados e o histórico
detalhado do paciente também é muito
importante.
Então, a estratégia terapêutica central
do protocolo Recode não é um tratamento
único, e sim um programa personalizado e
cinético desenhado para abordar os
contribuidores
específicos pro declínico cognitivo.
Então é baseado em sete estratégias
principais, né, que o eles chamam de B7
ou breadsent 7, que seria a dieta
ketoflex, que é a dieta rica em plantas
e cetogênica, que enfatiza a
flexibilidade metabólica associada a um
jejum de 12 horas, sendo que dessas 12
horas são 3 horas antes de dormir, que
você tem que ficar jejum. Essa esse
jejum pode variar de 12 até 16 horas. É
importante para fazer a limpeza do
cérebro, das proteínas disformes,
induzir a tofagia, que é o processo de
limpeza celular do corpo. O exercício é
muito importante
para melhorar o fluxo sanguínico
cerebral e aumentar o BDNF.
Também para ativar o sistema linfático
para reduzir o betamiloide. O sono de 7
a 8 horas por noite é muito importante.
Esse sono reparador também facilita a
limpeza do sistema linfático noturno
e também ajuda a regular, acalmar as
células gliis do cérebro para evitar que
elas ataquem os neurônios.
Importante
lembrar que muitos desses homens e
mulheres também têm hipoxemia noturna
pela pneia do sono. Tem que ser tratado
isso também para garantir uma boa
oxigenação cerebral nesse período. O
gerenciamento do estresse com prática de
meditação e mes.
A estimulação cerebral através de
atividades que estimulantes, como uso de
software de treinamento cerebral, BRHQ,
aprender novas habilidades como idioma
ou instrumento musical. e manter uma
forte conectividade social. E o detox,
que foca em identificar e remover os
dementógenos são químicos associados com
a demência, né? são metais pesados,
toxinas do mofo e toxinas também
derivados do plástico.
E a suplementação direcionada também é
muito importante.
Teve um estudo bem interessante em 2021
que foi uma prova,
né, de caso,
uma um estudo de prova de conceito com
255 participantes e que mostrou
realmente que funciona esse protocolo.
O estudo demonstrou que o programa
é multifatorial, é muito importante,
deve ser personalizado e pode modular
significativamente os fatores de risco
metabólicos e estabilizar ou melhorar a
função cognitiva.
Então, nesse estudo de prova de
conceito, teve desfechos metabólicos
muito importantes. Houve redução dos
marcadores inflamatórios da resistência.
da glicose de jejum e da vitamina D,
houve um aumento significativo. Então,
mostrando que esse protocolo, sim, tinha
potencial de melhorar marcadores
metabólicos relacionados à melhora
cognitiva.
Em termos de desfechos cognitivos, houve
sim uma melhora do Montreal Cognitive
Assessima, né, que é um teste
padronizado, né, de função cognitiva.
Isso teve dados claros aí de
estabilização melhor através do grupo de
participantes. Então, os resultados
foram mais pronunciados, estaticamente
mais significativos em pessoas que
tinham comprometimento cognitivo menos
avançado. Então, quanto menos avançado a
doença, mais resultado teve em P em
termos de estatística.
Então, para participantes com uma
pontuação basal moca de maior ou igual a
19, a melhora foi altamente
estatisticamente significativa.
E uma melhora estatisticamente
significativa também foi observado pro
grupo maior com a pontuação basal maior
ou igual a 10.
Então o o protocolo é mais efetivo
quando implementado antes que ocorra um
comprometimento severo.
Essa parte aqui são dois casos que
melhoram bastante com protocolo recode,
dois estudos de caso. O caso um é um
homem de 66 anos com apoê 4 positivo,
que tinha momentos ceniz e múltiplas
anormalidades metabólicas. Depóis 10
meses no protocolo recicold, a insulina
em jejum caiu de 32 para 8, a proteína
ser reativa caiu de 9 para 3 e a
ressonância mostrou que o volume do
hipocampo tinha melhorado do pessentil
17 para o pentil 75. Então teve uma
melhora muito significativa.
O estudo de caso dois é um homem de 70
anos
com uma história de 12 anos de perda de
memória acelerada. E após 6 meses, a
mulher notou que o declínio tinha parado
completamente. Ele demonstrou melhores
objetivas em lembrar rostos, horários e
números no trabalho. Então esse caso,
apesar de ser uma evolução muito mais
longa, teve a parada de progressão da
doença.
Existe críticas ao protocolo,
principalmente a relacionado à falta de
estudos randomizados do plegoo.
Então, existe uma Dra. Joana Helmut do
Centro de Memória e Envelhecimento da
UCSS, desculpa, UCSF,
e que destacou eh que não existia
evidência suficiente porque a maioria da
evidência era de casos descritivos e ela
criticou dizendo que não tinha um rigor
metodológico de ensaios clínicos
randomizados, mas eu vou falar sobre
isso mais adiante, tá?
E também outra crítica é de que existia
um custo financeiro muito alto, que os
pacientes tinham que pagar taxas aí de
inscrição de
pro Apollo Health. Consulta dos
profissionais eram caros também 450 por
hora e um trabalho de laboratório muito
intenso e extenso, né, e caro, chegando
a mais de 850
e muitos exames não cobertos pelo plano
de saúde,
tá? E também também tinha essa questão
do conflito de interesse, porque existe
essa situação da crítica sobre a empresa
que o Dr. Bradsen montou, Apolo Health.
que comercializa o programa, treina os
profissionais por uma taxa e vende
também linha específica de suplementos.
Então, eh, houve essa, esse
questionamento contra questão de
conflito de interesse, contra a
monetização.
Só que vamos responder essas críticas
aqui.
A crítica referente ao alto custo
protocolo recode merece uma análise
contextualizada
e vamos comparar ela com alternativas
são convencionais, especialmente as
drogas que surgiram nos últimos anos,
né? Os anticorpos monoclonais são as
estrelas atuais que foram provadas pelo
FDI para os Heimer, tem custos
excepcionalmente altos e muito maiores
do que o Ricold e tem benefícios
clínicos muito questionáveis. Por
exemplo, o AD do Canumab do Helme, ele
tem um custo anual de $8.000 1.000 e tem
evidência de eficácia clínica tão
controversa que a própria FD americana
teve divisões internas sobre aprovação
ou não.
O medicamento na prática, ele demonstrou
só uma desaceleração pequena do
declínio. Já o Lecanemabbi
custo de 26.500 00 por ano.
Também teve uma desaceleração modesta do
declínio cognitivo de 27% ao longo de 18
meses. Não teve nenhum caso de reversão.
Tem que fazer infusão a cada 15 dias e
tem que monitorar para efeitos adversos
graves, incluindo dema cerebral e
microemorragia.
O Donanemab também que tem custo chega a
30.000 por ano, também tem os mesmos
riscos aí de sangramento cerebral
e edema cerebral.
Então, comparando com o Recode,
investimento do protocolo Recode nos
Estados Unidos entre 5.000 a 10.000 no
primeiro ano, tá? E é muito mais
abrangente, é bem menor do que essas
drogas e tem mais resultados positivos.
Deixa diminuir um pouquinho de tamanho
essa tela aqui.
Pronto.
Bem, agora pra gente encerrar essa aula,
ah, eu queria falar desse estudo
Evantea,
tá? Que é um estudo que tá sendo
desenvolvido nesse momento e que
demonstra aí grandes potenciais, tá?
Esse é um ensaio clínico randomizado
multicentro que foi concluído agora em
31 de outubro, mas os dados não foram
totalmente processados ainda, em que
foram recrutados 72 participantes com
idades entre 45 e 76 anos, com
comprometimento cognitivo leve ou
demência precoce em 600 nos Estados
Unidos. E os participantes foram
randomizados dois para um para receber
um protocolo de medicina de precisão
personalizada, que é o recolde.
E isso foi abordado inflamação,
resistência insulina, deficiências
hormonais, exposição a toxinas, fatores
vasculares e lacunas nutricionais.
E os desfechos primários incluíram o
Montreal Cognitive Assessment, né,
aquele teste cognitivo, o índice
neurocognitivo CNS science,
questionários de cuidadores, volumetria
de ressonância magnética e biomarcadores
como PETAL, né, proteína tal 217 e o
NFL. Então, os resultados preliminares
mostraram
que uma melhora na cognição maior do que
vista em qualquer outro estudo, com
diferenças grandes, clinicamente
significativas, estatisticamente
significantes entre os grupos de
intervenção e controle, adicionalmente
demonstrando scores reduzidos de
depressão. E em caso documentados
normalização dos achados de ressonância
magnética por marcação de espinha
arterial.
Então, baseado em dados pilotos
anteriores, mostrou que 84% dos
participantes melhoraram com aumentos
médios do CNS Vital de 10 pontos e
prevenção da atrofia cerebral típica.
Então esse é o primeiro ensaio clínico
randomizado, validando a superioridade
da medicina de precisão sobre o cuidado
padrão paraa doença de Alzheimer. Então
essa validação científica rigorosa
que estavam aguardando. Então esse
estudo ele representa o marco histórico
na medicina. A primeira demonstração
controlada e randomizada de que uma
abordagem de medicina e precisão
multifatorial pode não apenas
desacelerar, mas reverter o declínio
cognitivo.
Então, o futuro
da clínica prática não é mais os estudos
randomizados duplos cegos de muitos
múltiplos pacientes, tá? O futuro da
prática clínica é o saio N de1, que é um
desenho de estudo no qual o único
paciente atua como seu próprio controle.
Ao coletar medidas basais detalhadas,
introduzindo uma intervenção e medindo a
mudança, nós podemos estabelecer
causalidade para esse indivíduo com alto
rigor estatístico.
Então, os ensage N de1 tem maior poder
para detectar efeitos do tratamento de
condições heterogêneas do que eles
eliminam a variabilidade entre os
indivíduos.
Tá? Então, a pergunta principal é: isso
funciona para mim? Ao invés de isso
funciona paraa pessoa média? Tá? Em vez
de você pegar milhares de pessoas e dá a
mesma coisa, você pega a mesma pessoa,
dá muitas coisas para ela e você vai
alternando de acordo com os exames e
você junta essas várias pessoas com
protocolos personalizados e coloca ela
numa análise estatística. Então, quando
você tem 100 de N de um consecutivos
mostrando benefício, você tem um
conjunto de dados que é
indiscutivelmente mais robusto do que um
ensaio clínico andomizado, tá? Esse é o
futuro, tá? Dess desse tipo de análise,
como é o caso do Alzheimer.
Então é isso, pessoal. Eu vou encerrar
por aqui. É bom que eu tive uma ideia de
eu tô com slides demais, eu tô
estourando fácil os 20 minutos. Eu vou
ter que reduzir essa apresentação aqui.
Que que vocês acharam?
Sogra do meu irmão
estava com 12 anos de cama de Alzha.
Quando ela perdeu o sentido, não ficou
mais preocupada com nada.
Ela multiplicou o tempo de vida, acabou
muitas doenças. Algo incrível
realmente, né? É uma taxa muito muito
grande do futuro aí de doenças.
Bem, pessoal, o que que vocês acharam da
apresentação?
Eu vou ter que reduzir o número de
slides. Eu vi que aqui eu vou ver
exatamente quanto tempo deu, mas com
certeza estourou o tempo. É só 20
minutos de apresentação.
Obrigado, Cleid Van.
Muito obrigado, Alice Vogel.
Obrigado, Maria Helena.
Vou levar, fique tranquila.
Bem, pessoal, vamos encerrar então aqui,
tá? Então, nós teremos a nossa próxima
live na terça-feira da semana que vem,
quando eu voltar de viagem, tá bom?
Um grande abraço, um beijo no coração de
vocês.